[Music]
so Dave we meet again
it was just what nine months ago that
you and I were hanging out here at the
fifth nine lounge at next we were
talking about your new book I think so
what have you been up to since we last
spoke
you know it's cloud it's only one of
Google's fastest growing businesses so
not much really you know video games
rock climbing a lot of quinoa mostly
that sounds about right pretty sedate
anything anything work-related yeah I
mean lots of stuff mostly working with
customers and doing everything we can to
teach the world what it means to be an
SRE and how to do it well so when
attendees come to next what can they
expect when they visit us here in their
59 lounge well really what we're hoping
for is to have those deep conversations
about how it is they go on their essary
journey we're still kind of at this
stage where we have to really prove to
people that no this is not just
something that only works at Google you
know it can work anywhere okay let's get
down to business and get to the
nitty-gritty of sre how do we help
customers move towards implementing sre
practices I also there two things you
really have to do one you have to make
it easy for them to learn all right so
we wrote these two best-selling books so
we have a Coursera course with a lot of
writing and public speaking and then you
have to make it easy for them to
practice it in the tools right so
there's a wonderful announcement today
from a stackdriver team about SLO
alerting and era budget monitoring so
those are other two things two ways you
have to attack that problem
fantastic so what is Google doing to
help our customers meet their own SOS
you know I think the best thing a
customer can do
- reliably meet s loz besides building
good products it's actually share their
monitoring with Google like if you're
using stackdriver you set up an SLO
dashboard you can actually share that
with us so that when you have difficult
moments and you will it becomes faster
for everyone to devote and so what is
people - what is Google doing without
products to help customers implement
those SLO Sandero budgets themselves my
my personal Goulet goal at Google is to
make sure that it's easy in every
product to practice essary principles
that roll outs and roll backs are item
potent and easy when you're doing them
on I don't know GC GC ERG ke you saw the
announcement this morning of our new
kubernetes hybrid and on-prem solution
we're gonna make some other
announcements about SLO monitoring and
burn monitoring in those solutions - so
we're really building at every layer of
the stack
fantastic now I've been hanging out with
the few sres
you hear a lot about accepting failure
is normal how do you recommend customers
go about moving from every error is a
problem to the mindset of failure is
normal you know a big problem is that
for so long we've all been living under
the tyranny of perfection we expect
perfection and I would say to customers
tell me one system designed by humans
software hardware economic political
anything you want that's ever been 100%
reliable and they can't and you know why
they can't because nature's never built
one either so once you accept that it's
not possible to do then the question
becomes well how much failure is
acceptable because you've got to have
some and that's where then we get into
the conversations about error budgets
nestlings that's a good segue so how do
you see customers becoming effective at
managing the workloads of their SRA
chains okay so you know there are some
good rule-of-thumb limits about the
number incidents you can really have
during a non-call period or how much for
your project time you can have so I
think a good rule of thumb for people is
if you see your teams are spending at
all anything less than 50% of their
calendar time their clock time on
engineering projects they're headed for
toil and they're not managing the load
well but we can you come talk to us we
can help you manage your way through
that
and speaking of that you know what are
you a recommendation to customers on how
to take that first step of their journey
towards sre well they're a bunch of
things you can do we've got to two
best-selling books if you go to
google.com /sr you can read both of the
books for free we have a course on
Coursera specifically on SL O's that's
really very popular if you're here at
the show come by v 9 and talk to us
Ari's talk to me or anyone else if
you're a Google cloud customer you can
talk for free with the Siri team the
customer reliability engineering team we
are a group of long tenured esterase and
our job is to teach you how to adopt
essary and make that easy and
comfortable for you fantastic all right
thanks Dave Eadie's always a pleasure
[Music]
you